do you do you think there is any
circumstance where it is better for a
human being not to be born
than
to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it
oh that's really hot like let's talk
about ukraine right now like oh i'll
give it even better i'll give you i'll
give you a better example let's talk
about slavery
would you say it was better for
a child slave to not be born
than to be born and go through slavery
but then potentially have the chance for
freedom depending oh
that's really hard that's uh it's very
subjective it's very like
because there are some people who go
through [ __ ]
and they're like um so statistically and
anthropology anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh nigeria and ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
western societies and they've got much
less
and it's because you know the little
things mean more to them so it's like
we look at them as quote-unquote charity
they have more meaning in their lives we
look at them as like quote-unquote
charity cases and a lot of westernized
people are like oh africa is poor africa
is exposed but actually they're very
happy they're very happy with a lot less
than what we are
and it's very subjective it's very like
i do not have the
um
i do not have the power to determine
what makes a good life to anyone but
myself but i'm just i'm just asking the
question i'm gonna ask you as well like
do you is there any
is there any circumstance where you
believe that a life being unborn is
better than the life not being born so
a big thing i
love um
yes or no
um i i don't i say i don't have a black
or white yes or no but a big thing a big
fact is so in i believe it's sweden 100
of embryos screened for down syndrome
are aborted 100
because they believe an individual with
down syndrome
won't have a good quality of life
and i fully disagree i work a lot with
people with developmental disabilities
and so people are like oh so if you've
got and um i interviewed cambridge and
they said this is the evidence that if
you have if you're pregnant and you live
in a uh built up area and uh carbon
emissions it means you're more likely to
have a child with autism and they said
okay discuss this with me and i went i'm
not going to discuss it and they were
like okay why and i said okay so you're
telling me if i live here you want me to
argue about whether or not my child is
more or less likely to have autism and i
just went it doesn't matter to me and
they're like why and i was like because
if my child has autism i don't care i
was like i will love my child regardless
of how it's born yeah yeah
i just don't understand how you can't
answer that question because nothing's
black or white yes or no like you can
either think of an example or you can't
i can think of an example for pro and
example for con as in like can you
is there any example where you can think
of
that a life has so much suffering it was
better that life was never born in the
first place
yeah i could think that but then i could
think the opposite so you can have
something so then so i would then say so
the answer to your question then to the
answer to the question originally is
yes as in you do believe that a life it
is better
you do believe there's a situation
where it is better for a life not to be
born if it's life was to entail so much
suffering
but then that is dependent upon my own
bias and my own well
you're asking for your opinion yeah yeah
ah like that's it you say slavery
obviously you'd be like i wouldn't want
anyone to go through slavery but then
there are people who go through slavery
who could be like well actually
this is my reality however xyz
is good about my life so in spite of
slavery
i've got a good quality of life like
it's so who am i to tell you that your
life isn't good like oh no we're just
not just asking for like okay yes or no
it's all it is is all it is is that can
can you think of a situation
where in your opinion it was better
for that person not to be born than to
go through what they went through in
life
i can't well then i would say that out
if you can't then i would say the answer
that is no then you believe that no
matter what suffering that life may go
through you believe that it that human
being being born will always be better
than not being born
but no i don't because that's it
no i don't because that's it it's not
black or white it's not yes or no
everything is the middle part of
everything and like not everything but
technically everything is the gray area
because
i can say for my opinion so that's it my
mom didn't want me to be born she's she
had a mental breakdown two years ago and
was like i wish i never had any any of
you and i'm there like my life is really
good and in her mind she's like your
life is [ __ ] right your projection is
[ __ ] and i'm like no helen like my life
is really good
and so
who am i to tell who am i to decide ah
so this is i think it's women i think i
think it's women a lot of times when you
have to admit something that kind of
goes against your belief system we try
to avoid the question and i think if you
if you said that like in essence like
you'd be admitting to something against
your belief no i think that's just
that's because it's it's the idea
but something's like it's like a little
grounded but it's a black or white
question
but um nothing is backwards so i did
yeah dialectical behavioral therapy and
it's okay with dbt and it's all due with
no we don't have to be black or white
yeah everything is in the grade i don't
know i don't know what dbt is so like
his but his question is like really it's
really black or white if you can either
think about example of thinking yeah
you have to be yes or no black or white
am i waiting for this for this question
for this question like it's either well
i was gonna say when when kit said like
oh no and i went well yeah no but then
you expanded upon it went well but i
don't agree with that part i agree with
some of the no yeah and i agree with
some of the yes yeah so it's a bit like
it's it's not
i hear what you're saying i ask you
pearl do you think um there's any
situation you can think of whether it
was better for life not to be born then
to experience that
i mean like
i probably would have aborted hitler
it's probably the only one
i'm like pretty pro-life but like i
probably would have aborted now
like knowing what i know
um but i mean without like
you can't possibly know so i would say
no
like i can't think of a an example other
than hitler yeah
maybe or you know maybe like a couple
brutal murders like i watched true crime
like what's the difference between
murder and just execution really it's
just perspective i think
[Music]
but then can we appreciate that that's
not a hard no
because you've got an exception that's a
great area that's the venn diagram i was
just i was just trying to be funny but
here i was just i was just trying to be
funny yeah but there's there's some
truth in it because you're just saying
do you know what because because in a in
the case of abortion like you don't know
you're never gonna no you don't so so
what i'm saying is like i actually
i actually wouldn't abort like hitler
well i'd only a boredom knowing what i
know now but that's not a real situation
right so like like and honestly like i
don't think we have the right to play
god
because that's what you're doing you're
playing god then do you believe that
that all depends on if you believe in
god that really i do yeah yeah that's
true
that's true